When knitting with the ribber, sometimes
the ends stitches can be problematic.
Adding extra weight with claw
weights or 7 weight hangers can help.
Some machines also have
ends stitch pressure plates.
These are the pressure plates
for a brother, KR850 for
a standard gauge machine.
After casting on and knitting a few
rows to get the cast on comb out of
the way, drop the ribber bed slightly.
At the end of the main needle bed,
slip the left and the right plates
over the sinker posts, and then slide
them towards the knitting position.
The presser along the
very edge of the knitting.
Raise your ribber back up and make
sure the working yarn isn't caught.
Positioned properly, these little
presser plates won't interfere with
your knitting and they may help
the end stitches knit more cleanly.